[Musique]
sati dragon bonjour bonjour bonjour aux
auditeurs de la première
alors vous êtes dentiste vous avez 62
ans et vous êtes candidat à cette marie
vous allez mener la liste ensemble pour
des ans kai et sept maris
c'est ça c'est ça c'est exactement ça
alors pourquoi vous présentez alors je
me présente à cette marie parce que il y
à un chaos politique à cette maille à
0,6 et s'est défait de tous les autres
candidats a auparavant
et la chose qui est importante aussi
c'est qu'il ya des choses il ya des gros
dossiers dont je veux parler entre
autres la du luxe la zone doc c'est
quelque chose de qui s'est passé à 7
paris alors qu'il était député qui
n'avait fait aucune intervention en tant
que député il fait une demande pour la
du luxe la douleur que c'est un
pesticide monstrueux qui est pire que le
chlordécone
parce que là on a parlé du club école
mais il le fait en toute connaissance de
cause il est en train de pourrir le sol
est de pourrir les gens de cette marque
est de la partie alors je comprends bien
que vous voulez vous voulez en parler il
ya pas de soucis mais on est quand même
dans une campagne municipale
là vous là c'était qu'à l'époque où il
était député
absolument en tant que député il n'a
rien fait mais là la seule chose qui les
fesses il a demandé une dérogation pour
l'as du luxe il est en train
d'empoisonner la marque mais sept maris
aussi parce que cette marie c'est une
terre de cannes aussi d'accord la
dérogation avait été accordé la
dérogation a été accordée à monsieur à 0
nous avons les textes la demande et la
dérogation donc pour ce fait il faut que
le peuple ça méritait sèche à qui ils
ont affaire
alors puisqu'on ne vous pose la question
et dit oui je les fais je n'ai fait que
de dire de faire la demande
donc ça il faut absolument que le
peuvent s'arrêter le sèche et qu'on ne
peut pas on doit lui lui m quand on
rouge carton rouge le 15 mars
je ne peux pas le laisser là alors vous
voulez désengage et sept maris ça veut
dire quoi des antis sainte-marie 10 à
kayes le terme est fort des haqqani ça
veut dire que cette marie au fond de
l'eau cette marie n'avance pas et c'est
un terme qui dit qu'il faut qu'on ait de
l'action et non de la parade
la parade tout le temps se mettre en
avant il adore les titres mais n'assume
jamais les fonctions jamais les
fonctions
là il veut y va maintenant aux élus aux
élections municipales et l'a bien dit il
ne va que pau cap nord il veut présider
un capteur il veut un fauteuil il ne
veut pas d'eux sera portée et on a bien
vu que pas de vérité députés dans toutes
ses actions au niveau de la députation
et au niveau de la mairie
il n'a jamais rien fait ce n'est pas un
homme d'action c'est un homme de parade
donc on peut pas lui donner encore cap
nord dans la mesure où le nova 100
faussé cette machine n'obtiendra rien
non plus qu'est ce qu'il manque pour qui
pourra voir ce qu'on a vu le nombre de
candidats importants à cette maille
qu'est ce qui manque pour avoir une
unité des candidats je sais que vous
avez un contact notamment avec monsieur
des roses avec d'autres candidats
pourquoi il n'y a pas un seul candidat
revient à une unité l'union
non c'est que nous sommes déjà vu
plusieurs fois et nous avons décidé d'un
commun accord qu'il fallait que l'on la
table de toutes parts c'est comme ça que
seulement que nous pouvons avancer notre
sens parce que il faut qu'il se sente
encerclé parce que nous avons tous des
choses à dire nous avons plein de
dossiers et les dossiers sont très très
très nombreux
alors pour vous le maire de sète marie
vous avez lancé ça lors d'un débat chez
les concurrents le maire de sainte marie
est un spécialiste du feng shui oui mais
celle du feng shui parce que lui et
n'arrête pas de harceler moralement les
emprunts municipaux y en a deux qui ont
gagné le pousser et en a 25 qui ont été
déplacés et ces gens vivent dans la
terreur et lui il dit à tous tout chacun
tous les employés sur pas fait ça m'a
dit a cependant giro - mas cap en
dessous donc c'est de là que vient le
terme en dessous quelles sont les
grandes lignes de votre programme les
trois grands axes on a 30 secondes
rapidement les trois gonzague revoir la
gestion la sécurité et l'aménagement la
santé avait effectivement le
développement et l'éducation et la
culture
d'accord reprendre la gestion pourquoi
on encore 20 secondes la gestion parce
que cette marie à 16 millions de dettes
c'est de cette marie à 42% de la
population sous le seuil de pauvreté
cette marie à 13 millions de millions
d'investissements
cet appareil ne peut pas avancer dans ce
sens on ne fait que des dettes que des
deux candidates et sept maris paix trois
cent quarante mille euros banc chaque
année se livreront je vous remercie
merci beaucoup